e
e e
good morning everyone and welcome to the
house committee on Health and Human
Services and elderly Affairs we have a
full day of hearings scheduled on five
different bills but before we get to
those I'd like you to please join me in
the Pledge of Allegiance
pledge allegiance to the flag of the
United States of America to the Republic
for which it stands one nation under God
indivisible with liberty and justice for
all thank you
everyone the first bill to be heard
today is House Bill 72 and I will
recognized Prime sponsor representative
Jess Edwards good
morning good morning uh Mr uh chair and
members of uh Health and Human Services
elderly Affairs I'm representative Jess
Edwards I represent Rockingham District
31 which is Auburn Chester Candia and
Deerfield um I'm an Alum a longtime Alum
now of this committee um and so it's
always good to come back and visit with
you uh today's um Bill House Bill
72 uh extending the commission to study
tellah Health Services is is very short
very easy to wrap our head around if if
you if you look with me on um the page
with all the writing uh I'd encourage
you to start at line
14 basically what we're doing with this
bill this is a study group that uh whose
time has come and gone it's expired and
we've published our final
report uh as we were coming to a
conclusion we started to talk about uh
whether coming to an end was U the right
thing to do and uh it was a strong uh
belief of the of that committee that we
should just do one more report a
supplemental report report uh why would
a supplemental report um be a reasonable
thing to invest in uh it's uh because
the final data that we used to do the
final
report um was heavily influenced by
covid and co uh we concluded really had
an impact on the way in which T medicine
was used an original purpose of the
committee was to determine uh what the
natural normal Trends are these days
with tele medicine and to help determine
whether or not there were things that
could be done to encourage its its uh uh
acceptance and and growth under under
the belief that uh it's a vital tool in
improving um the tripod of uh access
cost and quality and because we think
it's an important emerging thing and
because we think we had uh skewed data
from covid we wanted to U let it run
another couple of years so that we could
get um status quo data uh and include it
in the supplemental
report now if you jump up to line 8 uh
we determined that the original charter
of the of the um committee was just a
little incomplete and would have been
better had we also taken a look at at uh
Federal policies explicitly look at the
federal policies to see what the trends
were there to um uh
encourage uh or maybe discourage tele
medicine that's entirely possible but we
didn't look at the federal policy issues
and then um there was no Charter for the
committee to potentially recommend any
legislation not that there is
legislation we'd recommend but we just
wanted to make sure that the the members
of the committee knew knew that uh that
was a possibility if we saw something
that was worthwhile so um so that's what
hb720
[Music]
so that that's the bill um Dr Palmer
representative Palmer is on that
committee too uh and he was but part of
these recommendations I think I think
he's a co-sponsor yes he's a co-sponsor
so you when after I leave you got people
to ask okay what do you really think and
so uh I'll take questions if there are
any Mr chair sure uh representative
Woods thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question um
I've been involved with tah Health here
in the state for probably the better
part of 30 years right um and um my
question is um is there was there any
consideration to making this a continued
committee because judging from at least
from what I continue to read and my
interaction with some of the or national
organizations about the time you finish
this report is going to be time for
another report uh things are changing so
fast especially with AI uh it's it's
integration U the American Medical
Association uh is is a big player in
this Arena uh a number of independent
organizations are really uh being big
players uh and I'm just curious um it it
seems like this would be uh something
that would best be served with almost a
standing committee at the risk
of bring another committee but was there
any consideration uh thank you for the
question I I think the uh it wasn't an
explicit consideration what we were
looking at was this particular committee
was was was terminated at the end of the
final report and we we thought that we
really weren't done uh I I I agree with
your long-term Vision I I first got into
tele medicine believe it or not in the
60s at the University of Nebraska with
their program when I was just a kid and
I was interning as a volunteer
um and then is a a DOD tele medicine
test bed deputy director in the 80s so I
I I believe as you seem to the the
potential for virtualizing the Health
Care system and and tele medicine is
going to be maybe the backbone of that
and then over time we'll be able to add
other components like we're going to
continue to add the Diagnostics we're
going to do the AI and and and so so I I
I would like you to know that I agree
with you and that the chart Charter that
you're asking for can be carried over
into um a a longer term committee the
emerging medical Technologies committee
which I chair uh and we're going to have
our first meeting in February that's the
sort of topic that um that we would like
to include in that committee because
there's going to be this massive
convergence of technologies that are
going to create potentially a new sort
of virtual environment now because
healthc care moves slowly that could be
20 years you know but but I I I think I
think your sense is right um I I I would
recommend at this point to just keep
this bill narrow just extend this one
more time that'll give us time to
synchronize it and Inter leave it with
the emerging medical Technologies
committee and I think your objective
would be met that
way follow up uh this is educational for
me I was out of the legislature for for
semesters we missed you uh but um the
emerging Technologies as you know I was
originally a physicist and I'm very
interested in the emerging Technologies
this is a sidebar but um is that a
standing committee or uh we we set that
set up for um a 5-year life not knowing
whether or not uh touch bases with you
yeah let's talk about it um I think the
the the the timely aspect of this is if
you're interested in that committee
we're interested in having a Democrat
added to it um we lost one to U
retirement so you could talk to your
leadership and I don't think it's all
been appointed yet
other questions representative
McGrath thank you I was wondering if you
could expand on what synchronization
with federal policy does that mean that
we would have to follow whatever the
federal policy is so is so as you know
um federal policy if it comes with money
usually comes with strings and
synchronization and that regard would be
if we want their money we do what they
want um Uhn organization beyond that
though could be uh the extent to which
they include any research or any
findings or any recommendations I I I
don't know what I don't know yet about
that uh I I do know that the Department
of Defense still has um a version of the
uh organization I was in in the 80s uh
that explicitly looks at these emerging
Technologies and and uh and uh tella
health and I intend to go visit with
them to find out what they are doing at
the federal level and what issues
they're bringing in so I I want to
create a Communication channel so some
of it if we want their money and there
is money then we would do it and
otherwise it's just being informed so
that we have a better sense of the
future other questions
seeing done thank you all right thank
you very much have a good day yeah you
too also signed up to testify is Holly
Stevens with nami of New Hampshire
good morning chairman members of the
committee my name is Holly Stevens and
I'm the director of public policy at
Nami New Hampshire of the National
Alliance on Mental Illness for the
benefit of some of our newer members
could you tell us what n Nai stands for
the National Alliance on Mental Illness
great thank you you're welcome um Nami
New Hampshire is a nonprofit Grassroots
organization whose mission is to improve
the lives of all people affected by
mental illness and suicide through
advocacy education and support and I'm
here today to uh speak in support of
House Bill
72 um during the uh time that it was
meeting since uh
2020 um I served as the representative
from a nonprofit social services
organization representing the patient P
perspective and um was a part of that
commission is it did a lot of good work
and learned a lot from the data and a
couple of things that the data showed um
particularly when it comes to mental
health is that um mental health
psychotherapists and substance use
counselors about half of their
appointments are tella Health
appointments and the other thing that we
found was uh from the claims data that
was provided by the New Hampshire
insurance department and the Department
of Health and Human Services was that 80
to 90% of all claims filed for TAA
Health were Behavioral Health
claims um so this is particularly
important in the mental health care
Workforce crisis that we're facing as
well as the access to care that we're
facing with folks who may not have
transportation they may live in rural
areas where there's not a lot of uh
providers or may have things like child
care or work um uh
our executive director has been going
into uh
places employment um Workforce companies
um in talking with them about how they
can use tella health for their employees
to support them so that if they have a
mental health appointment they can go to
a room have that appointment and then
carry on with their day without having
to actually leave so tella health is
going to be critically important um as
we try to deal with a lot of Workforce
challenges across the sector um and for
those reasons um we're in support of
this bill um we know that the work is
not done the the commit the commission
found that this is an evolving
um where the the de the data is still
evolving on this um and we are just
coming down from covid and seeing where
it's going to all shake out so for those
reasons we are in support of this bill
and I will take any questions if you
have any thank you any questions
seeing done thank you thank
you also signed up to speak is
representative William Palmer a member
of our committee and a co-sponsor of
this
Bill thank you Mr chair I just wanted to
take a minute to say that I been going
around to various places specifically
medical um staff at Valley Regional and
my Hospital Mount es cutney and talking
to them about how important um this area
is to me is to them and they are now
regarding it as sort of a critical piece
of primary care access and that and
their biggest concerns are that um that
some of the agencies like Medicare has
been they've been talking about whether
they continue to pay for it and um so
that's part so I think continuing to
study this and figure out how all these
pieces go together is critical which is
why I'm really in support of this bill I
don't really have anything more to say
to that except that there's a you know
broad support from the medical community
and given the lack of primary care
access in New Hampshire pretty much
anything we can do to improve that is
key so I'll take any questions if
anybody has any any
questions yes representative
mlan yes thank you Mr chair and and
thank you representative Palmer for
taking my question so you mentioned that
some of the the funding and coverage
might be under threat um I thought you
said Medicaid um is hearing the same
thing from private insurance and others
as well it it's it's sort of an ongoing
thing and right right now I know s of
the American College of Physicians is
doing a lot of lobbying to maintain
coverage and some of it's not that
they're going to stop coverage
altogether but it's you know whether it
continues to be fully funded and for and
for what the other areas that are
important is for example if you're a
physician in Vermont um and your patient
is in New Hampshire there are a lot of
issues like that that really are sort of
going to be very important to to solve
so that tele medicine really can be as
helpful as it can be because we have a
lot of Border everywhere and so there
all of those issues there's
no right now there's
no there's no one thing that that we're
that I'm particularly worried about but
it's the whole spectrum of of
availability of
services yes representative Woods thank
you Mr chair thanks for taking my
question um as with electronic medical
records um for the private practitioner
there is always an ancillary financial
burden to sell set up the software have
somebody who could maintain it um that's
an extra charge overhead is there a
similar sort of number that you can put
your thumb on about is there a similar
overhead shall we say for you mentioned
expanding the primary care but there's
the downside is you have to have the
proper environment and to create that
what's that burden
so I don't know the whole answer to this
I because the the part of the answer I
don't know is what private practitioners
who may not be using an electronic
medical record are doing um and how that
might work in other words sure they can
do it over their you know iPad or or on
the computer but how does that fit in uh
in a lot I didn't mean to I I use the
electronic medical record just as an
example but as a standalone so so the
practices that mount scotney and the and
a lot of the so a lot of the so
Dartmouth Hitchcock Health has a whole
sort of system built into their
electronic medical record which must
have taken something and there's and
there is a whole thing that you have to
follow where you have to document that
this is a tella Health visit and so
there's extra extra time if you look at
these notes half the note is sort of
documentation of the so there is there
is some extra burden there but you know
overall that the practitioners are like
may maybe so but it's still really uh an
important
yeah representative Weber I I had just a
point of order Mr chairman isn't it true
that we have a relatively short period
of time to deal with the bill and the
bill is about a study committee to study
these issues so I'm I'm wondering if we
should try and limit our questioning to
the study committee rather than the
underlying issues that all of us are
really very very interested in cuz so
please come to the study
[Laughter]
meetings other
questions okay I'm seeing none thank
you uh I I have no one else signed up to
testify on House Bill 72 does anyone
else wish to
testify seeing none I'm uh seeing no one
I'm going to close the public hearing
House Bill 7 2 our next hearing is in 10
minutes on House
Bill
um if you
don't um so again I'm going to close the
public hearing on House Bill 72 our next
hearing is scheduled in 10 minutes at
10: a.m. on House Bill 58 so we'll be in
brief recess
[Music]
not here today but he was just here tesy
is there anyone else who is missing or
has been
substituted
um on where I parked my car that' be
cold
[Music]
just to confuse
you we were we
were
y next week and because Chris was
sitting here I said
oh hands down you guys are
better but no pressure I no if I was
SCI you guys don't
know actually I make jewelry so I can
like figure out how to do that
like
e
e e
I'm a
and you
can my sister and I went to Pei in
October
e
e e
um it's 10: a.m and I'd like to
recognize the prime sponsor
representative Wendy Thomas
thank you Mr chair and members of the
committee um for the record I'm Wendy
Thomas and I represent the town of marac
uh last uh yesterday I I emailed you um
a copy of this report and I'm going to
be referencing it so it's in your email
box if you haven't seen it yet um HB 58
uh which establishes a committee to
study legislative protections and
accommodations for individuals with long
covid is a good idea for several reasons
particular ularly when considering the
economic impact referenced in the New
Hampshire fiscal policy Institute report
which you have all been mailed long
covid is defined as a chronic condition
that occurs after SARS covid infection
and is present for at least three months
long Co includes a wide range of
symptoms or conditions that may improve
worsen or be ongoing anyone can get long
Co long Co occurs more of often in
people who have had severe covid illness
but often who get uh but anyone who gets
uh covid can experience it including
children most people with long covid
experience symptoms days after first
learning they had covid but some people
who later develop long covid do not know
when they were
infected people can be reinfected with
covid multiple times each time a person
is infected with covid they risk they
they have a risk of developing long
covid long covid symptoms and conditions
can emerge persist Revol resolve and
reemerge over weeks and months these
symptoms and conditions can range from
mild to severe may require comprehensive
care and can even result in a
disability while rates of new cases of
long covid have decreased since the
beginning of covid it remains a serious
Public Health concern as millions of us
adults and children have been
affected the report the New Hampshire
report highlights that almost
177% roughly 4,000 people of the state's
working age population have experienced
long Co this significant percent
percentage demonstrates the potential
for long-term economic disruptions
including individuals with long covid
who often experience dis uh debilitating
symptoms making it difficult or
impossible to maintain consistent
employment this effect overall
productivity and increases dependency on
disability
benefits also many affected individuals
face prolonged unemployment or
underemployment which leads to reduced
household income and decreases consumer
spending which also affects the broader
economy long covid leads to ongoing
medical expenses including treat
treatments diagnostic tests and
rehabilitation services for individuals
and families those costs can be
devastating especially for those without
adequate Insurance on a systemic level
increased Health Care demands strain
public and private Health
Resources this bill wisely acknowledges
that long covid disproportionately
affects marginalized communities which
are more more likely to work in
high-risk low low-paying jobs without
adequate health benefits and they also
have limited access to health care and
financial safety
nets targeted legis efforts would reduce
those inequalities by improving access
to accommodations and
protectors by involving multiple sectors
Health Care employment education and
Social Services the committee can
propose Holistic Solutions to minimize
long-term economic and social disruption
coordinated efforts are essential to
address the interconnected challenges po
posed by long covid such as ensuring
workplace accommodations and stream
streamlining access to health care and
disability
benefits the evolving nature of long
covid Demands a proactive approach
establishing a dedicated committee
ensures the state can respond to new
research and emerging challenges
efficiently minimizing economic Fallout
and improving Public Health
outcomes given the widespread and
long-term economic impacts of long covid
on individuals families and the state
this bill represents a forward-thinking
approach to addressing a pressing issue
the committee's work will help mitigate
economic losses reduce disparities and
promote resilience within the workforce
and Health Care Systems thank you and
I'll take any
questions thank you any
questions oh I'm sorry representative
Weber thank you Mr chairman and thank
you very much for taking my question um
I may have misheard you um but in one
point in your um introduction you said
about 7 about 4,000 people were affected
with long covid and then you said that
was 177% of our
Workforce and those numbers don't seem
to add up to me particularly well
because that would imply a Workforce of
about 25,000 people
uh I I I think the 17 14% actually
you're you're correct referred to the
22,400 people in the report that have
reported long Co okay they are not
necessarily out of work 4,000 are out of
work but
22,400 so so it was it was that was an
error on my part yes thank you so so the
22,400 is New Hampshire right correct
this is strictly on New Hampshire and is
a followup a followup so it's 4,000 out
of work and 22,000 some who have
experienced it correct okay got it thank
correct thank you representative I'm
representative woods and then
representative
Maser uh thank you Mr chair and thanks
for taking my question um being in the
medical community I certainly this is a
a very admirable project but how does it
differ from any other chronic disease
that we face and the similar kind of uh
uh factors uh that come into play in
terms of the workforce etc etc that
you've outlined how is it how does this
specifically different that would
warrant a a specific committee for this
particular specific medical entity thank
you for the question and that's a that's
a very good question um the reason that
I I believe that this committee should
be set up is because we're seeing viral
infections that we haven't seen before
like Co you know it's it's not just the
flu this is ongoing it's mutating um and
perhaps this should be changed from long
covid to post viral symptom uh disease
because there's so many out there bird
flu is on its way you know we're going
to have to prepare and we're going to
have to recognize that there are many
individuals myself included have
postviral symptomss that are
ongoing so it's a valid point that there
are many many diseases out there but
this is one that is specifically hitting
our economy great
and we need to we need to address
it representative merer yes thank you
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question um kind of off of what
representative wood said but so how do
we know that these long-term effects of
long are they long-term effects of long
covid how do we know that they're not
long-term effects of the actual covid
vaccine
I'm not sure how to address that however
if you have long-term effects from the
vaccine if you believe you do that would
be
um I would think it would fall under the
umbrella of this long-term effects from
covid whether it be the vaccine or or
the actual viral
inection follow so I I read the report
and it does mention the UN un vaccinated
um so are the vaccinated going to be
included in the study of this as
well if you suffer from postviral
symptomss from a covid infection I would
think you would be covered under this
study other
questions uh representative
mlan okay representative McCay
thank you Mr
chairman we're all aware that U the
legislative leadership is very concerned
that we keep forming committies uh
partly because they have to staff them U
and I'm wondering if there's some other
way of assisting in this issue without
forming another
committee because the
implication is that the Public Health
Community is not living up to their
responsibilities and I don't think
that's at all what what you
intend U so that I wonder if there's
some other way that we can help to deal
with what is an
important health problem without forming
another committee
is I I'm not sure what the question is
the question is is there some other way
to help the uh Public Health Community
in their work without forming another
committee I okay so I I understand the
question and what I can say is that
finding some other way to help the
community is exactly why what this uh
study committee is about um and and in
our my my committee where I where I sit
we're also warned about um having so
many study committees however isn't it
our job to study and to come up with
solutions for our constituents follow up
follow up u i I think he answered my
question and the question is how can we
sell that on the
floor uh because that I agree that's a
major problem uh
but we need some evidence that it's not
being
addressed and and how to deal with
it representative mlan do you have your
hand up and then representative Woods
yes thank you Mr chair and then
representative pmer and thank you for
taking my question so I'm just um I'm
just curious as to the scope and and
where you see the need and you know
where you what what is the area of focus
going to be is is the area of focus
looking at um improving the health
outcomes or is it more like you said
that you you're seeing gaps in coverage
and people are out and so they're
experiencing financial hardship so
you're really going to be focusing in on
there that area I'm just trying to
understand how expansive the scope is be
and where you envision it going um sure
if you look at uh in the in the uh
Bill uh lines 11 through
28 uh explained what the uh committee
would be looking at uh specifically my
concern is the economic
impact thank you you're welcome
representative
Woods thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question um just as um as
you formulated this were you familiar
with the uh long covid Clinic uh at
Dartmouth um with I forgotten Your Name
Escapes me uh um but um he started at
right at the beginning of co uh did you
work with him in terms of formulating
any of this material um I did not um and
I'm aware that they have a clinic up
there and that could be part of it is to
make more people aware that there's a
clinic because a lot of people just
don't know where to go I mean they're
stuck with these symptoms and they don't
know who can help
them representative
Palmer so representative Woods started
with the exactly where I was it's uh Dr
Parson and it is a whole inter
interdisciplinary team that is working
and they're they're both they're both
available for treatment for people who
think they have postco and they're also
doing a lot of research and so they may
be looking into a lot of the questions
that this committee would look at and um
so it might be worth I mean it's
definitely worth talking to those guys
thank
you other
questions seeing none thank you thank
you no one else has signed up to testify
on HB 58 does anyone else wish to
testify seeing no one I am going to
close the public hearing I thought this
might go on longer obviously uh given
given the the nature of Co and and the
um the interest and and the concerns and
challenges that presented to our country
and State uh so it's it's sometime
sometimes hard to gauge you know
participation in the hearing so I
apologize for it's going to be a
relatively long recess but um our next
bill isn't scheduled to be heard until
11:00 a.m. House Bill 370 so we will be
in re recess for the next 45
[Music]
minutes so that a little
while
e
e e
what it
happens good good morning it's still
morning and welcome back to health and
human services and elderly Affairs uh we
are our next bill uh to be heard is
House Bill 370 the prime sponsor is
representative Bernardi he's not able to
be with us and he has asked
representative mlan who is also a member
of our committee to uh introduce the
bill so representative mlan
thank you Mr chair members of the
committee my name is uh Mark mlan I
represent Hillsboro district 15 and I'm
standing in for the prime sponsor of HB
370 uh representative JD Bernardi um
he's testifying uh in Commerce and
consumer affairs as Prime sponsor there
and he asked me if I could come in and
uh read read this testimony on his
behalf um HB 370 reestablishes a
commission to study the delivery of
Behavioral crisis services to
individuals with mental illness whose
impairment is primarily due to
intellectual disability uh the issue
stems from the definition of mental
illness found in RSA
135c colon 2x mental illness means a
substance impairment of emotional
processes or of the ability to exercise
conscious control of one 's actions or
of the ability to perceive reality or to
reason when the impairment is manifested
by instances of extremely abnormal
behavior or extremely falter perceptions
and he highlighted this next section it
does not include impairment primarily
caused by intellectual
disability um so and that's that's the
the root of the problem every year there
are about 10 cases of individuals who
experience a significant enough
behavioral crisis that they are brought
to a local hospital those hospitals
without appropri staff and services for
these episodes essentially just
Warehouse the individuals without
treatment for up to three or four weeks
before releasing them there was
testimony um when the committee heard
the bill last year both pro and con on
removing intellectual disability
exemption from the mental illness
definition as a solution uh to re
redefining responsibilities within the
system uh this committee and the Full
House last year passed Amendment
language on a Voice vote which when it
went to the Senate they came back and
they proposed a commission the house
concurred with the other bod's Amendment
and the governor signed a bill
establishing the commission the purpose
of the commission was to identify
appropriate procedures within the mental
health services framework to ensure
individuals experiencing a behavioral
crisis and whose primary impairment as
an intellectual dis is an intellectual
disability receive adequate And Timely
treatment however um the appointment of
commission members by the governor was
considerably delayed you know we were
into uh the middle of October and some
members were never appointed we were
barely able to get a quorum um I was
asked to serve as clerk on that
commission and the the um the HHS
representative actually said do you even
have enough people for a quum and it had
just come in uh that morning and so
given the deadline which was November
the 1st everybody at the commission said
we really there is no time to do the
work we we've run out of time and so the
the recommendation was you're going to
have to come back you're going to have
to reestablish the commission and so
that's what this bill does this bill
reestablishes the commission with an
adequate timeline to complete the the
task um and it was recommended uh when
they did meet that one time that um the
the report outdate be pushed out with an
interim report by November of this year
but the final report out to November
2027 it doesn't need to take that long
but it just prevents uh them running
into the same problem that they
encountered last time so that is not the
intention but it was recommended by the
folks on HHS maybe you should consider
that with respect to the dates so um
representative anardi also says that
individuals who testified in favor of
the bill last session were not REM
marshaled uh obviously to Advocate uh
for the commission and that was because
he believed that the issue was settled
by the creation of the Commission in the
first place and so he was just basically
asking now that it could be uh
reappointed with the time to complete
its task and um he will be available for
questions after his testimony and
commerce and consumer affairs um but I
don't know how that's going to go but um
that's basically um the the main thrust
of his testimony and I'll do whatever I
can to answer any questions on his
behalf thank you so in other words the
commission never really did function
have a chance to do anything last time
right so I understand it no it it just
showed up like we we barely had a quorum
with the last people being appointed
that morning but then we don't we don't
have time so the the recommendation of
the commission was to reestablish the
commission okay representative Nel I
guess I'm very confused because I was on
a commission on the Behavioral Health
crisis Services was that the the
commission I was
on all right thank you because we did a
lot and they recall almost the exact
same thing as I'm staring at the name
right
here representative McKay
thank you Mr
chairman uh I support this commission
but for different
reasons our
society
generally has a
prejudicial approach to mental illness
and mental
retardation and the
language that's in this bill is typical
of what
happens it is very difficult
uh to put the two
categories together to say that metal
retardation is the same as mental
illness but that's what this does uh so
I would hope that the commission would
look into that we understand in our
society that there's a built-in
prejudice against mental illness and
that's one of the
difficulties of individuals who want to
treat the mentally ill uh if if the
commission could take that on that is a
Monumental problem in our
society uh but I would strongly
support looking into that or at least
getting it out into the public that
there is a difficulty in our society
accepting mental illness and mental
retardation and that affect our ability
to fund those programs uh so here's
another
opportunity uh to get that out into the
open thank you very
much representative
Weber thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question and um my
question is very specific to the bill
because I'm trying to dredge up my
memories of last time around and am I
correct in remembering that the real
Focus here was on the subset of
individuals who when they are taken to
the hospital because of Behavioral in
behaviorally
inappropriate things that they have done
they are then told that they cannot be
treated because they as persons with
developmental
disabilities are specifically Exempted
from the definition of mental illness is
is that am I remembering that yes as the
root of the problem yes thank you
represent yeah that is correct so if you
have severe autism for example um well
that's the primary driver here and and
so that's what's driving the behavioral
thing so we're just not going to put you
at New Hampshire hospital we're just
going to Warehouse you here and
ultimately um the symptoms are going to
uh sub side or not and then you're going
to go back to your home without really
having received any treatment thank you
and a followup followup actually I think
that last
phrase took care of my followup so the
the the specific issue was for that
these individuals they're not receiving
any treatment at all or or certainly no
uh treatment that is in any way
particularly appropriate to their
situation and I think that's why
representative Bernardi used the word
warehousing in his testimony okay thank
you very much for the
explanation representative Woods thank
you Mr chair and thank you for taking my
question um I'm I sort of have the same
how the categorization and I'll use an
example um fetal alcohol
syndrome maybe sort of what we might
StreetWise say that they're
intellectually developed but their
decision
making uh is very adherent
um would that be some someone um and
that that is devastating to society
fetal alcohol syndrome uh and they can
have straight A's some of them um but
their frontal lobe
capacity uh would seemingly fit is that
am I understanding the differential
you're trying to make um I'm I'm
certainly not an expert and I'm
certainly not representative Bernardi
but I it is I I believe that that would
be covered under what the commission
would look at
yeah yes representative harad thank you
chair just a comment um I may be at a
little bit of an advantage here having
provided the exact services in question
uh 40 years ago and now I do it again a
day or two a week uh here at Riverbend
um you've really described the the
challenge I think uh representative
Weber it's really about what do you do
with these 10 cases when you have a an
involuntary emergency commitment law
that expressly prohibits people with
developmental disabilities from being
involuntarily committed I think
representative McKay hit it on the head
too in that there you are at 3:00 in the
morning in an emergency room with a
16-year-old who's behaving uh terribly
and
diagnostically you you really can't
reasonably sort out is this a function
of a developmental disability or or some
other psychiatric uh challenge so you're
really these emergency rooms are just uh
awfully stuck and whether you have a
seasoned psychiatrist a seasoned
emergency worker you know working the
case you just simply can't sort it out
that quickly so the law does uh pose
some real challenges there's also a
training issue for the uh the people who
are actually doing the work as well
having done the work and having run in a
psychiatric emergency service for a
number of years I can tell you your
staff people are not uh trained to make
these kind of subtle uh diagnostic
distinctions in this complicated legal
you know uh uh Arrangement as well so I
think it's a very good and reasonable
thing to take a peek at uh and and move
forward with the Bill thank you thank
you representative Maser yes thank you
Mr chair um and I'm not sure you can
answer my question but it was kind of
off of what representative Nagel asked
um or alluded to that are there other
commissions SLC committees out there
right now that may may be doing
something similar that this can just be
wrapped under instead of establishing a
new
commission I'm I'm unaware of another
commission that is working on this
specifically person so I I I can't
answer that question there may be but I
am unaware of it
other
questions seeing none okay thank
you um would either of the individuals
in the audience like to testify I have
no one else signed
up okay uh if no one else wishes to
testify I'm going to close the public
hearing on HB
370 uh our next hearing is scheduled for
12:30 uh on HB 63 so we will be in
recess until 12:30
[Music]
oh I'm sorry
sorry
e
e e
good afternoon everyone and welcome back
to the house committee on Health and
Human Services and elderly
Affairs uh we have the next bill we have
scheduled for public hearing is
hp63 prime sponsor is a former member
and former Vice chairman of this
committee representative Erica Leon and
she is already
position welcome back representative Lon
thank you Mr chairman and members of the
committee um quite envious that you are
all sitting on this committee with each
other but I'm also quite excited about
my new opportunity in executive
departments and
administration um I represent the town
of Derry which is Rockingham 13 and I am
here today with a bill that um would
have been brought to you by another
former member Gary Merchant um however
he was not victorious in his election we
can't let good Poli y fall to the
Wayside um so I am here today to help
ensure that we can have access to the
newest FDA approved emergency
epinephrine product um especially for
children in in the appropriate settings
so I've distributed three different
pieces of paper to you um the first one
here is why we're here it's the FDA
approval of this nasal spray it's called
nephy as the brand names so um I might
refer to it as nephy a few times right
now we allow camps uh um basically
summer camps or or whatnot and schools
to have uh to administer this and to
have the epinephrine um on hand so that
they can administer it to a student who
needs it right now our law speaks about
Auto injectors because until last August
9th we had epipens but we had no other
way to get epinephrine into uh somebody
somebody who is experiencing an
anaphylactic reaction so this actually
uses pretty known technology it's using
the same device as Naran so it's
approved uh device that already people
already know how to deliver and is very
very easy to use it's smaller so it's
easier to have on hand and it actually
has a longer shelf life so it will be
good at the camp or the school as long
as they're not leaving it out in the sun
in the field it'll be good for 30 months
if they are leaving it out in the sun in
the field or on the dashboard of a car
it's still good for three months so if
they want to be that aggressive and make
sure that they have it out there on the
ball field with them at summer camp they
can do it and just replace it each year
since summer camp only lasts three year
three
months so this seems like a really
really big and daunting Bill considering
that it is uh nine pages long but what
it does is it adds nasal spray along
with the auto injectors um I have been
contacted by the New Hampshire
pharmacist Association because they
noticed um a little bit of a disconnect
in these statutes and the ones that were
passed last year that would allow them
to allow the schools to stalk the
epinephrine not in not specifically for
any specific student there was nothing
in the pharmacy statutes telling the
pharmacists that they could do it so
after a back and forth and some
conversation it was fine to let it
happen but when you're looking at school
nurses and when you're looking at
Pharmacists it's a lot easier to have
this in their statute and say that a
pharmacist made Spence up and have Auto
injectors and epinephrine nasal spray
pursuant to a prescription issued in the
name of a school postsecondary
institution or independent school a
school Under the direction of the school
nurse May maintain a supply of
epinephrine Auto injectors and
epinephrine nasal spray for use in
accordance with and it's the school
statutes so that would just make it a
lot easier and a lot cleaner um and
there's a really really big big reason
we want to make sure that we can do this
um this company that makes this new
nasal spray is has a program to offer it
to all schools all K through 12 Schools
public or private um as long as it's
allowed by state law they'll provide two
boxes of it so that's four of the nasal
inject nasal sprays um and they'll
replace them so this is something that's
going to increase access to um
life-saving care in our schools at no
cost to the state there's another
separate bill House Bill 677 that's an
education policy and administration that
will be updating those statutes and
dealing with that but the job of this
committee is to make sure that the
pharmacists can do what they need to do
and that we update the statutes on camps
and schools um in order to permit this
new novel technology so with that I'm
happy to take any
questions are there any questions
representative
Weber will you be obtaining the official
Amendment or should somebody from the
committee do that um I actually obtained
one along with representative groda
because she is a co-sponsor of the bill
um she and I looked at it yesterday
sorry I didn't get all the way down
through the I I saw the one with the
yellow thing but you've already got so
this is the amendment correct officially
that has the yellow language on it so we
have everything in front of us yes and
on that second page where it's yellow
highlighted there's an asteris which
shows you where it fits into the larger
scheme of all of those laws um because
one without the other is sort of
incomplete right thank you you very much
you're welcome although thank you for
this you're welcome I don't know how
long you need to retain that information
unless you're the clerk but it's good to
see representative Woods oh thank you Mr
chair and thank you for taking my
question um uh this is obviously a
needed entity and sort of a check the
box type thing U my question Senator
around uh doesn't seem to apply to
Industry um we don't necessarily have a
a big huge General Motors plant here
that might qualify to get such but um is
there any con consideration to include
uh industry uh in their ability to have
this available um thank you that's
actually a wonderful question I think
that would be going pretty far outside
of the scope of this but if you and I
want to drop something for next year of
this term I'd be happy to do that
because just like aeds save lives this
also saves
lives and um and actually one of the
other things is right now they list
price is around $700 but they have an
access where with insurance co-pays it
should get to $25 and they're working
with good RX where it's $25 even if you
don't have
insurance those of you in the healthcare
industry know how the list and actual
need to be
different other
questions seeing none okay thank you
thank you
sure thank you I've got
one I should I think she only gave you
one yeah that one in
doubt if you
didn't also signed up to speak is
Kristen Evans
it actually says Judiciary on it you
me
okay sure
okay feel free to pull another you have
another enough room there or you need
another
chair okay ma'am can can you spell your
first name
all right so um dear members of the
committee um for the record my name is
Kristen Evans and I live in pelum and I
am here today as a parent so not in my
official job um for me I'm here to
express my full support for House Bill
63 for me this isn't just legislation
it's life or death my 1-year-old son
Truman has life-threatening allergies
and every day I live with the knowledge
that a single mistake a single exposure
could change our lives forever when
Truman was first diagnosed I quickly
learned how fragile safety is seconds
matter during an anaphylactic reaction
those precious seconds can mean the
difference between life and death yet
hesitation or fear in administering
epinephrine is all too common
especially for those who care for
children these are the people who may
find themselves in the position to Save
a Life and we need to give them every
possible tool to act with confidence and
without
delay today Truman is here with me and
he will share his own perspective about
what it's like to live with the constant
RIS risk of anaphylaxis I've also
brought with me the three types of
epinephrine devices we rely on to keep
them safe I have the traditional auto
injector
this is the needle the
avq auto injector this one talks to you
when you open
it it walks you through it which is nice
but those are usually hard to get and
then we brought the nephy so if anybody
wants to see what it looks like um we
also have the so
um the nephy is small and portable and
simple enough for anybody to use um the
bill is not just about convenience it's
about empowering caregivers to save
lives it's about ensuring that when the
unthinkable happens those who are
entrusted with the safety of our
children have the tools they need to act
immediately and effectively I urge you
to pass House Bill 63 for every child
who depends on others to protect them in
crucial moments thank you for your time
and thoughtful
consideration thank you do you want to
take questions or would tman like to go
ahead and then we can ask them both of
them my name is fruman and I am 17 years
old and I live in P I'm here today to
share why passing House Bill 63 is so
important could you maybe P get closer
to the mic I'm sorry about
that my name is Shuman and I am 17 years
old and I live in pelum I'm here today
to share why passing house bills 63 is
so important to me and others like me
who live with life threatening allergies
since I was young I've had to carry an
iip pen everywhere I go it's just a part
of my life but but that doesn't make it
easy living with severe allergies means
I'm always thinking about what I eat
where I go and whether the people around
me are prepared to help if I ever have
an anaphylactic reaction it's not
something I can ever take lightly
because I know how quickly an allergic
reaction can turn into an emergency even
though I carry an iip pen and know how
to use it there's always the chance that
I might not be able to administer it
myself in those moments I have to trust
the people around me can step in and
help I don't know how intimidating that
can be for someone who has never handled
before that's why House Bill 63 matters
so much allowing schools camps and other
places to use epinephrine nasal spray
would make a huge difference the nasal
spray is easy to use and doesn't involve
a needle which can be scar for people
who aren't used to giving injections an
emergency when every second counts I've
have some something simple and
straightforward can save lives I try to
be prepared for anything but I also know
that I can't do it all on my own passing
this bill would mean that the people I
trust to look out for me would have have
an easier way to help if I ever needed
it it's about making sure that no one
hesitates when there's a tool that can
make acting quickly less overwhelming I
I hope you will consider how important
this is not just for me but every kid
like me who relies on others to step in
during a life-threatening situation
thank you for your time and for
listening to my story and I opening to
answering any questions you have great
thank you any
questions seeing none okay thank
representative Weber
this is a little out of the way but I I
was just wondering if if the two of you
would like me to take a picture and
email it to you so you to have a record
of your testimony but I didn't want to
do it without your permission I
appreciate
that great job Truman great
job I love your name too thank you I it
to do you want to look at the neew do
you want me to pass it around so you can
see I would yes I could want pass all
three yes representative
damus thank you Mr
chairman this is a would you
believe would you believe that I
actually found myself on the floor of a
bathroom of a restaurant uh I think it
might have been last Sunday or the
Sunday before I'd eaten something that I
didn't realize was going to react and uh
I don't have anaphylaxis so I don't need
the the epinephrine but I was on the
floor and I didn't have my phone and I
was on the floor for I don't even know
how long I finally was able to get up
off the floor and get to my husband who
brought me home and I suffered for three
three or four days so I know what it's
like to have terrible allergic reactions
to foods and um environment so I'm glad
you guys are bringing this to us you're
welcome
very scary are there any other questions
any
other saying n okay thank you very much
thank you thank you and we'll get these
items back to you shortly
momentarily I have no one else signed up
to speak on hp63 does anyone else wish
to
speak seeing none I would I'm not going
to close the hearing public hearing on
HB
63 our next hearing is scheduled for
1:15 on
hb26 so we'll be in
recess we're being so efficient
today
e
e e
representative Weber moves a to pass uh
and representative Delma seconds sure
representative um Weber
uh the amendment is uh now I've lost my
pieces of paper
again uh
67h and it simply allows supplies to be
kept on hand that have not been
prescribed for a specific individual and
because it's quite possible that
individuals go into an anaphylactic
shock the first time and don't have
anything having them on hand is very
important so um I would move the
adoption of
20256 7h okay thank you representative
damus do you wish to speak to you a
secondly microphone oh
sorry thank you Mr chairman I fully
support the amendment as well as the
bill itself the body of the bill because
of the fact that it introduces a new um
method of of delivery for important uh
epinephrine in case of anaphylactic
shock for due to all kinds of
allergies okay is there any other
discussion on this
motion again the motion oh
representative Woods uh thank you I just
like to offer further support uh my
daughter is a pair of at a local Junior
High uh and worked with kids who don't
have sufficient support
but often times with their other
disabilities have allergies which may or
may not be known right uh and this
occurred just last week with her uh and
without this kind of
availability uh this kid would have
died thank
you any other
discussion I seeing none I'll ask that
the clerk call the rooll again the
motion is ought to pass on amendment to
House Bill 63 amendment number being
2025 hyen 00
67h Mr
Clark CL roll uh please say yes or no no
you have to go yeah
that's rep Missour
yes rep
mlan
yes rep damus
y rep kofalt is not present rep
PA off
yes clerk votes
yes R marel
yes R McGrath
yes R Boer
yes R McKay
yes rep Woods yes
rep
Palmer
yes uh CT rep Sebert for reptiles
yes rep L
montine
yes rep hartnet
yes rep
Lucas
yes and chairman McDonald yes
okay that makes the vote 16 Ys zero
Nays motion passes okay thank you
representative Weber uh
repres defer representative delus you
want to make a motion of op to pass as
amended yes motion to pass as amended
okay okay and also I'd like to move to
have it put on the consent calendar okay
well okay sorry okay so a motion has
been made by representative delus have
ought to pass as amended and
representative we seconds do either of
you wish to speak to your
motion think we've already covered it
okay uh so again the motion is O to pass
as amended on House Bill
63 um when you ready Mr Clark
all right we'll call the rooll
again uh on motion ought to pass as
amended as as amended as amended uh R
Meer yes rep McLean
yes rep lams
yes rep PA off
yes clerk votes yes
rep marel
yes rep McGrath
yes rep wber
yes rep McKay
yes rep Woods
yes rep Palmer
yes uh rep c for rep tles
yes rep L
montine
yes our partnet yes
ref
Lucas yes chairman McDonald
yes vote is 16 to zero motion
passes and representative
delus thank you Mr chairman I move that
we uh put this on the consent calendar
okay if there's no objection we will put
that on the consent
calendar all right excellent
congratulations okay excellent
start so help me out here yes okay who's
writing the report representative damus
love it uh and and again
I could I get that representative delus
could I get that in the next day or so
so uh if you can just send me an
email yeah you just write your own you
know usually just indicate you know what
what the vote was
I usually just get emails from people
people if you email them then they don't
have to retype it they just cut yeah
state state the motion the vote and
and it's all new to me so it's who Moved
who seconded I know mean no yeah no I
just I always just make it up on and
that way I have
a take a picture of this and it to
you need you need you need this
separate the well
might the way I usually do it and I
think the way you're supposed to do it
is the motion would be TP for just the
amendment and then it would be the bill
number
TPA and and then
change usually usually I believe it's
fistic I always speak I guess that's the
advantage of pencil yeah but you got
either way yeah to
either because sometimes an amendment
fails the bill
passes would just be you're not writing
this I'm writing this but you could TP
on the amendment only
yeah and again there were separate
people making emotions too Lucy
made I don't think would if they wanted
that would they put that on
here cab well he he has information too
but again the vote on the amendment
sometimes is different than the vote on
the full Bill too sometimes an amendment
will pass what the bill will fail the
otpa will fail so then this is otpa otpa
down 34 I thought it was only
34 if there's a new better way or great
way to deliver the same drug to help
save someone's life it just makes sense
and it's so nice and LU that made the
motion
on she made the am motion on the
amendment she made the motion on the and
she'll be writing the report who
delus but but she didn't make the motion
on the amendment no I know but it
doesn't doesn't say on here doesn't ask
you right usually usually the one of the
same but so anyway I'll send this and
see if they have a problem all right
it'll be easy to change
yeah this right coun yes minority Noone
that
exactly I'll this to
Sean
okay I wasn't speak not here if you want
sure let me uh let me I'm going to
adjourn the executive session on House
Bill uh
63 uh we have concluded that that
business and it is now 1:15 p.m. so I'm
going to open the public hearing on
hb26 uh the prime sponsor is
representative papichi Mueller he is not
present uh but one of the Coes sponsors
is representative Dan Maguire and thank
you representative McGuire for being
here that works out well yes uh we will
need a pink card from you after your
testimony or before either one yeah he
um I'm sure he's coming but anyways um
thank you very much Mr chairman members
of the committee for the record my name
is Dan Maguire I represent the town of
Epsom this bill is kind of a followon to
a bill that we passed last session that
was sponsored by myself and um
representative papovich Mller and
representa of merchant um I guess former
represent of merchant and um so that
bill was um
for to put an exception into law for
certain testosterone
treatments um that were of gel form so
testosterone if as if you don't
understand is a is a kind of a another
word for steroid and so um it and so
when when uh men typically older men
have a have a low testosterone they're
prescribed testosterone treatments and
kind of the lowest level of that
treatment is a gel form and so um it's
the kind of treatment it's a kind of
situation that doesn't get cured it just
gets managed sort of and so once you're
on these kind of treatments you're
you're essentially on them for the rest
of your life or until you know at some
point maybe you wean yourself off or
you're too old to to use it I don't know
but in any case um it's for long periods
of time but the problem was that because
chemically steroids and testosterone are
essentially the same thing or they're in
the same category they're they're a
class I think it's class two drug um and
so you're only allowed in general for
this class of drugs to get a a one month
prescription well that means you're on
something for the rest of your life or a
long period of time you're going to pay
12 co-pays instead of the normal four uh
it's just the hassle of of you know
re-upping your prescription frequently
and and um uh ordering stuff frequently
and all that sort of stuff so so uh the
legislature was kind enough to put in an
exception for these kind of uh gel
treatment testosterone so representative
papovich Mller um wanted to expand that
to injectable testosterone which is kind
of you know if if the gel form is sort
of not enough for you right if your if
your situation is such that that um it's
not strong enough for you I guess then
you then the next step is this
injectable form and it's essentially the
same thing but he put in to this that
you have to have had your prescription
your Monthly prescription for 12 months
so you're on it kind of regularly you've
been doing it for 12 months before you
can move to a a 90-day I guess it's
technically a 92 day um prescription but
it's essentially the same issue the same
drug Etc but it is a stronger version of
this of this drug but it's it's only
prescribe to people who really need it
and and you know would use it in a
regular way
so okay thank you any
questions yes representative
McGrath um so I'm a retail pharmacist
and this 12
month Monthly prescription before you
could get it would be a nightmare to
manage in a retail Farm phy people don't
go to the same
pharmacies
the you know we have if they might be
from out of state I don't I that's that
is a nightmare situation for pharmacists
so the question thank you for the
question representative so I guess your
your question is sort of how does the
pharmacist
manage how do they know that a person
has a 12- month has had a 12-month
prescription
and I guess
um they would have to maybe maybe uh
call the person's do do you ever call
the person's doctor and say have you
given them 12 months so so I think the
doctor is the one who makes the
prescription right so so doesn't the
doctor say now I'm giving you 90 days so
the the doctor would have to know okay
I'm giving you one month one month and
so on okay you've hit a year now I'll
start giving you 90 days
correct follow
up thank you
um yeah I mean if it's on the doctor and
the pharmacist can just assume that the
doctor is following the law
then if then that would work but it
often falls on the pharmacist so I guess
the question would
be you know is there any language that
can go in there to make it so the doctor
is the one
that has to follow up on following that
law yes thank you for the question I
guess that's a level of detail that
maybe I can't answer quite right um
because you're right that this reads as
though it's the pharmacist who's in
charge right because it it says may be
filled for a 90-day Supply it doesn't
say may be written for a 90day supply
right so so maybe this is a detail um
that representative papovich Muller
would have to maybe bring an amendment
for you or something like that I I'm I'm
not sure what I don't know whether he's
thought about this or
not representative
mlan thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question you may have
mentioned it in your testimony and I
might have missed it but what was is why
is the prior 12 months essential why not
just go straight to
the um the the 92 days yes thanks for
the question so I think the whole point
of this is to kind of avoid the the
everybody's fear with prescription drugs
is that patients will doctor shop and go
here and get a prescription and then go
there and get a prescription and then go
over here and get the same prescription
and all of a sudden they've got these
dangerous drugs in way more volume than
you know they they should right so I
think the concept here is that you've
been going to the same doctor for a year
he's seen you for a long time you've
gotten that one that those 12 one
monthly prescriptions and so you're a
regular person right I mean you're
regular patient of this thing you're not
somebody who's you know I'm here the
first day and I all of a sudden I want
this big
quantity I think that's the concept
of any other questions and may may I add
to that slightly the reason that wasn't
an issue with the gel version is because
the gel version is so weak that that a
90day
Supply is not a you know it doesn't
build big muscles or whatever you see
what I mean you know I I'm I'm a patient
who uses the gel version and my doctor
once made the made the comment to me
that if you want to abuse this stuff you
would need a bathtub full you
know you know you know a couple of
bottles isn't going to do it right and
these are not cheap drugs I mean these
are like uh you know technically the the
bottle is $100 or more right so it's
anyway any other
questions I'm seeing Noone no no other
representative did you have your hand
up thank you for taking Mr chair and um
thank you for taking my question which I
don't know that much about this but it's
part of it in order to monitor patients
taking this injection for side effects
which might be
harmful um possibly but
I that that's I guess that's beyond my
knowledge I I I'm not a doctor so I I
suppose it's possible but I I don't I
don't think so I think it's more about
the class of drug you know we have this
system of certain drugs you just simply
can't have some drugs you can get but
only in the hospital some drugs you can
get uh with a very short prescription
other drugs you can get with a normal
prescription and other things are over
the counter you know what I mean so
there's a classification system and I
think it's just kind of where this
particular one lands right I I I it's
possible but I I don't think so i' I've
never let me put it this way for my
condition where I'm I've been given
testosterone I've never had a doctor
want to see me more than once a year
right
so you know I mean it's it's a very slow
moving kind of situation you know what I
mean you see a very specialized doctor
you see them once a year they say okay
you know things are about the same and
you know it's like
that other
questions I'm seeing no other questions
thank you all right thank you Mr
chairman and again the pink card don't
there you
go um representative Murphy Mr Thomas do
you wish to testify on this bill um
hb26 good to see you Mr the
representative Murphy thanks for coming
in um if no one else wishes to testify
I'm going to close the public hearing on
hb26 that is the last public hearing did
I hear
something okay
um that is the last public hearing we
had scheduled for today uh we will be
coming back tomorrow uh excuse me next
week next Wednesday for another day of
public hearings until then we will be
adjourned thank
you
e
e for